welcome back to new rockstars it's me mt
and this is a breakdown of the
peacemaker season one finale it's cow or
never so let's human torpedo ourselves
into all the fun hitting details and
things that you missed from this
incredible wrap up to the most unique
and amazing comic book tv show
experiences that i have ever witnessed
in my days because when the james gun
shoots he never misses pew pew but
anyways the season finale it's cow or
never potentially a play on elvis
presley's 1960s hit it's now or never
with peacemaker himself being a product
of the 1960s starts with the ridiculous
lyrics of steel panthers if you really
really want me playing in the background
in the very same van that they stole
from plaza moment veterinary clinic
which is hilarious considering that
adobe's last job was at an animal
shelter and yet somehow her new job
finds her working with animals yet again
but then we're almost immediately hit
with the true origins and motivations
for this live-action version of
peacemaker when he reveals that his
senseless murder of his brother keith is
what has pushed him to fight for peace
by preventing senseless deaths like
keats from happening which is a lot
different from his origins of his comic
book counterpart who initially
reluctantly becomes the peacemaker to
stop an arms dealer from stoking a war
between two south american nations in
peacemaker's first appearance in the
fighting five number 40 by charlton
comics with charlton of course being the
name of the fictional county of
evergreen in the peacemaker series and
the name of the news van at the very end
of the episode we then hilariously get a
vigilante calling adebayo his fifth best
friend while getting annoyed that chris
and her were taking all the fun out of
turning races into swiss cheese i mean
what's your problem guys
just kidding the murder is wrong which
very much goes to show just how much a
sociopath like adrian struggles to get
along with society because if chris and
eagley are one in two then three and
four are likely parkourt and economos
basically just everybody that he knows
the latter of which makes sense
considering vigilante's very sarcastic
concern for his health the post-credit
scene of the finale sarcasm i haven't
noticed you eating way more corn chips
than anyone human being should eat and
i'm not
worried that you're gonna die
but i am worried that you're gonna die
thanks and i really enjoyed how james
gunn allowed the audience to experience
the awkwardness of the team's last ride
in a goofy themed van following the
finale's theme song with a completely
silent arrival at their destination
framed like we are a passenger in this
van with them which is of course a huge
contrast to the very chill fun chainsaw
music friendship vibe the 11th street
kids had during their mission to glen
thai bottling plant earlier in the
season with that precious moment of team
unity being cherished by economos by the
end of the episode when he reports back
to work at bellerive penitentiary same
supervillain facility that he worked at
in the suicide squad movie and of course
i cracked up during leona's phone call
to task force ex-mom amanda waller with
waller assigning her most responsible
metaphorical child harcourt as being in
charge copy mom while apparently
actually listening to her daughter
adebayo's advice to call the justice
league who actually end up showing by
the episode's end in a very hilarious
cameo that i'm never going to forget
thank you aquaman for saying the f word
a small moment that also gives a little
bit more credence to peacemaker making
fun of the flash earlier in the season
at school have you ever met a flash yeah
i meant the flash like everybody else
has ever met him i thought it was an
unbearable d-bag and this also explains
why waller asks car court through
adebayo if the team can wait for backup
do we have time to wait for backup no
they're teleporting the creature out of
here the little clever foreshadowing by
james gunn and when the team is
preparing to kill that cow we get a down
on all the powers of peacemaker's five
remaining helmets out of the eight that
was introduced in episode one underwater
world scabies for all anti-gravity sonic
boom and of course human torpedo with
screwdriver bound for good and itchy
band being left out but i'm assuming
ichiban is for the scabies and though we
never got to see a flashback of augie's
days as the peacemaker when he was doing
racist [ __ ] in the past we did get to
see the proper execution of a human
torpedo when the white dragon attacked
the econo goat and the blunder twins
last episode before you know getting an
improper execution at the end of the
episode with leota sort of pulling drax
by attacking the beast from the inside
and hey in honor of one of the most
anticipated movies of the year our
friends at epic hero shop just released
three new batman themed shirts and two
sock designs they normally release new
merch timed with the release of the
movie or show that they're inspired by
but they're dropping this batman merch
early just for you so you can have it
just in time for opening night picture
this you're in line to buy popcorn and
you get a knowing nod from a guy working
at the register he leans in and whispers
hi i'm eric voss and now you've just
made a cool new best friend who can slip
you some free junior mints
our merch partners at epic hero shop
have all kinds of other cool designs
including two new shirts inspired by new
rockstar's favorite meme doubt villain
mephisto an epic hero has all kinds of
cool merch inspired by all of your
favorite properties and they're always
on top of the latest trends bubbling out
the stuff that we're all into at the
moment they even got a trust to bro
moving company shirt that would look
great paired with a new rockstars zip up
fleece and sign up for their newsletter
at the bottom of their website to get
notified about all the latest merch
drops and check out all of their
incredible products at
epicuroshop.com be your own hero and
then we get this really hilarious
exchange about how to properly execute
sarcasm if you're gonna be sarcastic you
should really warn people so there's no
confusion which is extremely reminiscent
of rocket raccoon's comment on sarcasm
in guardians of the galaxy vol 2. oh no
you're supposed to use a sarcastic voice
now i look foolish also directed by
god's gift to humanity himself james
gunn and i never thought i would
actually say this to an audience of
several million people but green arrow
has officially been canonized as a brony
with economos's task force x intel
confirming peacemaker's rumor dude goes
to brony conventions dressed in the back
half of twilight sparkle with a four
inch wide butthole drilled in the
costume no i actually heard that's true
about green arrow but that's the first
thing he said that's real and when
adrian echoes chris's commands to eagley
to pick up the helmet i feel like james
gunn was channeling that brotherly
energy of timmy and toby repeat timmons
from the sand lot
take the helmet eagley take the hell
eagley take the helmet colossus of cloud
the colossus of clouds and when the team
searches for the helmet eagerly
mistakenly dropped in the forest
[ __ ] peacemaker experiences his first
haunting of the ghost of his racist
father which is actually a big element
of the peacemaker character in the
comics from the 80s where peacemaker's
nazi dad haunts him from the grave after
peacemaker watches him dead himself
which means that we the audience will
likely be blessed to see yet another one
of robert patrick's amazing performances
as the despicable ghost of auggie smith
in the now confirmed season 2 which is a
relationship very reminiscent to batman
and the ghost of the joker in the arkham
knight game i really love that game you
should play it if you haven't and
peacemaker's fact about how often people
poop themselves after death one of the
things those warriors seldom talk about
is how often people [ __ ] themselves when
they die it's a touch of gray in the
white cloud of kicking ass is true by
the way because morticians estimate that
it happens around 20 to 50 percent of
the time so needless to say if you talk
[ __ ] about peacemaker uh sleep with
diapers off and not long after this
moment harcourt calls peacemaker my dick
schwarzenegger which is quite hilarious
considering that john cena has often
times been compared to arnold
schwarzenegger even posting an old
picture of a young shredded arnold on
his instagram one time and i found
economos's reaction of muttering no more
kaijus no bokaijus after losing his [ __ ]
at the sight of a giant ass caterpillar
kaiju completely understandable as i'm
sure the shock of having a giant
starfish interrupts his workday in the
suicide squad oh my god miss waller
we've gotta freaking kaiju up in this
[ __ ] stayed with him specifically for
the purpose of him and his therapist
having something to talk about but it
was actually butterfly lock's reaction
of a single tear dropping down his face
that i found more surprising as it shows
much like with mirn lock was technically
more human while possessed by a
butterfly than he ever was alive which
sort of gives goff's revelation to chris
the butterfly's peacekeeping intentions
for humanity more credence like goff
said we're kind of messing ourselves up
and when the team storms the ranch to a
theme song so nice that they had to play
it twice we got to see peacemaker do
some dope trick shooting with that
peacemaker shield that was lurking in
the background of auggie's armory
earlier in the season as well as getting
to see leota adabayo absolutely [ __ ] it
up queen that's that god-given natural
talent that walla was talking about in
episode one baby and finally when
adebayo airs off all of argus's dirty
laundry not only is she standing in
front of some really dope rude hollow
switch water posters which is a
reference to the really popular web
comic and some super dope funny posters
of dc comics characters as manatees like
hawk vanity superbanity and batman t but
her report also includes the sentence
taskforcex quickly assembled a team of
motley government agents or as one might
say a motley crew but that is it for
this breakdown of the season finale of
peacemaker what did you guys think of
the episode and the season let us know
in the comment section below you can
follow me at mastertainment if you want
to see me tweet some weird [ __ ] and some
really fun theories but more importantly
you can follow new rockstars wherever we
are on social media and when you do make
sure you hit that notification bell so
you get notifications every time we
upload a video and check out all of our
fun peacemaker shirts over at
newrockstarsmerch.com but anyways i'll
see you guys next time goodbye
[Music]
you